un million de steroide qui circule entre
Mars et Jupiter c'est ça l'évier
Hernandez directeur du Planétarium
bonsoir bonsoir oui un million peut-être
un petit peu plus en fait donc c'est ce
qu'on qu'on arrive à détecter beaucoup
mais mais on fait les choses pour
pouvoir les voir correctement et donc on
est un peu près sûr de ce chiffre là et
on arrive à voir les très très gros
aussi donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'ils vont pas nous surprendre on
sait qu'ils sont là
parce que c'est les petites planètes
qui sont très très
très
très bien la lumière du soleil et on
arrive
à peu près
et c'est là où
potentiellement ça devient très
dangereux parce que on peut se laisser
surprendre en fait parce que c'est
astéroïde ils peuvent avoir une
trajectoire qui va venir croisé celle de
la Terre
les dinosaures
ont pas la même chose la même chose
à
faire
dans
les
environs
de diamètre absolument incroyable il a
pas de gens mais
celui qu'on appelle celui de
en 2013 on a vu des photos et des vidéos
un peu partout je sais pas si vous
rappeler mais si c'est astéroïde avait
vraiment été vraiment rentrer dans
l'atmosphère terrestre et il avait causé
en fait de nombreux dégâts dans cette
ville de la Russie donc le risque et là
il faut il faut s'assurer justement de
pouvoir identifier série ce que la paix
de prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
agir pour pouvoir sauver en fait
l'humanité est la sonde art permet de
d'offrir des solutions
alors
de
trajectoire la lune tourne autour
parce que ça va être plus facile
pour sa trajectoire est pas capable de
mesurer correctement les effets de
à très court terme donc c'est ce qu'on
cherche à faire avec cet astéroïde là
par exemple
[Musique]
on en a
une qui va protéger la Terre de
possible pour pouvoir causer des dégâts
la terre il faut quand même rentrer sous
certaines conditions et notamment un
angle d'attaque
pour que on puisse rentrer
très très marrante
et puis on estime que c'est environ 1 à
2 sur plusieurs quand même dizaines de
milliers d'années pour être dangereux en
fait donc mais il tombe quand même sur
Terre 1 quantités colossales en fait
d'astéroïdes qui sont ces petites
par année quand même
parce que
ça
se passe très bien donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut pour pouvoir
à bientôt au revoir merci au revoir